all right i think this works
i can see my face
all right guys so let's wait a few
seconds for people to come in
um and then hopefully everything will be
okay
man you know when jordan peterson talks
about kind of going into the unknown and
doing things you're not used to doing
this is really this is really for me
this is really the kind of thing that
drives me that makes me extremely
nervous
um all right i've never been a very
technical person
and so you know all right so this is
working
i've got the chat let's wait another
another few minutes so that people can
come in
i got my images
all right okay so let's uh
let's go so i
i wanted to try this as a live chat just
because i figure
because it's a surprise chat there won't
be too many people uh there won't be too
many people in the chat
and so um i'll be able to kind of pay
attention to what you're saying and
maybe interact with you guys
a little more than i do in the uh in the
q a
um and a lot of people have been asking
me to do
an interpretation of the recent image i
did
of the flood as a cosmic image and
i wanted to make a color version i've
been i wanted to make a color version
from the start and so i
decided to wait until i had the color
version to do the interpretation for you
guys
so last week i put it out um you know
people can buy it as a print or
on merchandise or whatever and uh
and so i thought let's do this let's do
a color version it has a nice rainbow
which it's just
i just feel like now's the now's a good
time to talk about
you know images with rainbows i don't
know why and so
so i think that we can we can we can
look at the symbolism
here and i'll show you guys at the same
time hopefully i can make this work i'll
also
try to show you um some of the images on
which it is based
because it is not a uh it's not just
something that i took out of my
imagination but
it's based on several traditional images
as well
so i see brad is in the chat it's good
to see you sorry i didn't warn
you and other moderators that i was
doing this but
you know that's how it is
okay so let's go
and so the uh the image you're seeing is
of course a kind
i tried to i've been i've been i made
this image of the the image of
everything everybody has
seen it and i interpreted it but i
wanted to
also show people how this image of
everything it's
it's obviously there there's variation
in the way you can represent
the kind of the same pattern you can
represent it
through different angles and so i wanted
to try to maybe take a few
other stories in scripture and represent
the same
kind of cosmic pattern by emphasizing
that particular story
but then all also emphasizing different
aspects of this kind of cosmic
pattern because i always always want to
be careful people don't
um just equate the image with the
pattern in itself
you know the image is is trying to kind
of reveal this pattern to you
but it's not the full thing it's it's a
it's a it's a clothing right it's a it's
an image of something which is invisible
and a pattern which is invisible
um all right so so if you look at
the we can start with what is referenced
in terms of the
uh the image of everything the genesis
one where
the first one i did so what i wanted to
do of course is to try to show it
also this the fractal nature of reality
and so you can understand
very easily that this whole image of the
garden of eden
and what's going on there is ultimately
is ultimately now in here where you have
the garden
in the background and you have the flood
coming up to
the gates of the garden so this little
hill here with the four rivers and the
tree in the center which is now the tree
of life and which is equivalent of
course to
the cross here in this image here i'd
only put the two rivers but
traditionally it's actually more it's
more usual to show
the four rivers of paradise kind of
coming down the mountain
so i have the same structure with the
four rivers and the tree at the top
an interesting tradition about the flood
is there are many people santa seraphim
uh san diego from the syrian and other
saints talk about how the flood came
up to the gates of the garden but
the garden was never flooded and you can
understand
that as the idea of this pristine
reality which was preserved kind of like
the
ark itself but it was preserved at the
top of the world
it's something like the preserving of
the seed or the preserving of the
principles that are
at our top and there's some really wild
traditions which came out of this idea
that
the garden wasn't flooded for example
there are
interesting traditions according to
which um
according to who according to which
melchizedek
was you know i forget who it was someone
who was
preserved in the garden of eden during
the flood and then kind of came out
afterwards i forget who he's supposed to
be that's horrible though that he was
preserved
in the garden and then uh came out after
the flood which is why we say that
you know melchizedek has no father and
mother that he has no generation let's
say
um so the different traditions of things
that are kept in
the the garden um even during the flood
the idea of the tree of life being
preserved also
in the garden it's just different ways
of explaining
the the problem of the flood and how you
know
despite the flood you always need to
have something which is
which is preserved above so that then
the world can kind of
take shape from uh below again so this
is what i wanted to show
in terms of the relationship between the
uh
the garden of eden and the flood itself
and so the the image of the tree of life
it's complicated to show the tree of
life and i always struggle to
to do that it's actually rare that it's
shown in iconography usually the image
which is shown is
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil so i was wondering how to do that
and what i thought of doing was to base
the idea of the tree of life
on the image of the glory of god and so
you can see up above
this these three half circles
where the uh
let me close up here a little bit so if
you if you look at this
this section here you can see this is a
traditional way of representing the
glory of god which is the idea of the
divine darkness
which is behind the glory so there's a
dark circle in the inside and then you
see a lighter circle
next to it and then a white or a very
very light circle on the outside
this is something that you'll see often
in icons at the top of icons you'll see
it in the icon of
of the baptism of christ of theophany
you'll see it also
in sometimes the glory of christ himself
if you see christ
in the ascension or sometimes in the
anastasis
we see christ descending into hell
you'll see this kind of uh
mandurala that has a dark on the inside
and then light on the outside
it really is this idea of something
which is beyond name which is then
manifesting itself in identity
but behind this identity is actually
something which transcends identity
which is
which is beyond uh images beyond beyond
light
um and so what i wanted to do is to kind
of in the in the whole image you'll see
there's a lot of reflecting
where there's a sense in which the the
cause of something is the reflection of
the other
and this is what i wanted to show here
where at the top you have
this um this divine darkness which
manifests itself into light and then in
the tree
you have the light at the center which
is kind of darkening as you
leave the center and this is based on a
lot of traditions about
the the temple of course as the temple
had these thicker veils or the idea
from the syrian talks about the four
rivers of paradise which
as they go down the the the mountain in
paradise
get mixed and mitigated and are not as
pure as they are
at the beginning of their journey let's
say and so you have this this sense of
this light kind of darkening as you get
further and further from the center
but but when you when you balance it
with this idea of divine darkness then
you
you don't run the risk of just having
this uh
what i could say a kind of gnostic
vision or
a simplistic vision where we have this
idea that everything that's on the
outside is just in pure
everything that's dark is just bad and
everything that's light is just good
that's not that's the the the base the
cosmic pattern is more complex than that
um and so so you have the tree of life
which is at the top of the garden you
have the four rivers
and here this is interesting because a
lot of people were confused about
about these images the two the two
images that are
that are next to the uh that are next to
the tree
people were wondering we're struggling
to understand who that was and what i
wanted to represent was something like
before the before the flood and
after the flood and so the and also the
idea
of this you could say the relationship
between something
because there's a there's a pattern in
scripture which is that before
uh a flood or before a crossing of
waters
there's something like uh an ascension
there's something
there's something about someone going up
and
before the flood you have um
enoch and so this is a lot of people
thought this was elijah but it's not
elijah
the idea of having elijah there would
make no sense in terms of this story
it's enoch who is ascending into heaven
before
the flood but i'm using the trope of
um of elijah first of all because
if you look at very early manuscripts i
couldn't find an image of it though i
was looking
for it before and i couldn't i have it
somewhere
in my papers or i lost them during the
flood but there are earlier images
of representations of saints like enoch
in which he's represented in
the divine chariot and so that's also
why at the ascension christ
if you look at images of the ascension
you'll notice they have these wheels
under the older versions especially you
have wheels under the angels
because it's also christ ascending into
heaven in a divine chariot and so
all the images of ascension really have
this sense of the merkabah or this
divine chariot
which is the vehicle by which the saint
ascends
and so so this is enoch and then this is
actually noah
who is sacrificing after
the after the flood so before the flood
you have this kind of from the dry land
this this
going up of uh you know the holy one
and going up of the holy one or the
disappearance of the holy one
has something to do with the the
the flood itself you could say you know
or this transformation or this change
that's going to happen
um and so you see it's not necessarily
negative but there's definitely
this the change that's going to happen
so you see that with elijah going up as
well
you also see it with moses his body
being taken up
um as the before the the
israel is able to cross the jordan um to
go into the promised land
um and their virgins of course
the ascension of christ himself ends up
kind of being the culmination of all
that
and then afterwards you have the
sacrifice of noah and so you you have a
sense of
the the saying going up and then here
you have the
sacrifice going up but the blessing
coming down as well so we understand
this
as this new blessing that god gives to
noah
um it's hard it was hard to represent
this totally but you can also understand
that
at this moment when noah finishes the
flood and is on the mountain
you know the mount ararat he also
received the law
and so there's a sense in which this new
beginning is a sacrifice
it's it's also the receiving of a new
law for the new world which is about to
begin um
okay so let's look into the chat some
people say can you explain divine
darkness a little more
um i would say if you if you're if
you're interested there are many videos
on my channel that talk about
this idea of uh of divine darkness
and uh especially my chats on saint
gregor nissa
he talks about divine darkness quite a
bit and so
i think that um i think that you can you
can find the answers you're looking for
in that because it would be difficult to
go into it too much
to go into it too much into it right
here
um okay so above here above the
the um the rainbow we have
of course this cosmic image here you
have
let me just back up a little bit i hope
you can see my cursor
okay so here you have the sun and here
you have the moon
um and of course i'm trying to play a
little bit with color i'm not a super
i'm not super good with color
but i was trying to kind of use some
trying to suggest some symbolism with uh
with color and so there's this
a lot of people have noticed you know
how in uh christ and the virgin in some
traditions
you'll have christ with and with uh you
know with
with one color inside one color outside
and the virgin with the opposite
and so this is what i was kind of trying
to suggest uh the idea that
they're espec similar to what you have
here in the divine glory
and the tree of life which is that
you know there's there's a sense there's
a reflection of causation
and so here you have the blue on the
inside and the red on the outside
with the blue on the outside and the red
on the inside um
and so i'm trying to kind of show this
you'll see it all through the image
where this this it's almost like a yin
yang image you know where you have
the white dot in the black and the black
part
there's a sense in which uh the the
the motor of something is
there's something which you're moving to
which is kind of like you're moving
towards
not the opposite but that the vision of
the opposite is the drive of your
identity
you know and so as you notice something
let's say especially in terms of male
and female you could say
so the the existence of masculinity
uh manifests itself in a in a drive
towards the feminine
and the feminine manifests itself as a
drive towards the masculine
so this relationship is important to
understand because opposites
are related to each other they don't
just exist stand alone they
they're they're moving towards each
other and so that's probably the best
way to see
all of this but it's easier to show it
in an image form than it is to explain
it
so it's better to just create these
patterns of reflection so that people
can kind of get us
kind of see it and then and get a sense
of it so you'll see this all through the
image
the two angels of course having the same
pattern of
blue and pink and then pink and blue
um and then it goes down through this so
i don't want to talk about the the
rainbow right away we'll talk about the
rainbow a little later
let's talk a little more about just a
little more about the
the flood itself
and so of course
this flood is this the primordial
waters that are manifested again so you
can have a sense of
this this uh beginning of genesis where
it talks about the waters of chaos
so this is really these really are the
waters of chaos the same as
we could see um the same waters that you
could see in my image of everything of
course
and traditionally the the thing with the
image of uh
noah is just how much today it has
become uh
you know the idea that this story of
nora could be like a kid's story and
then you could have like little plush
toys about it is just
it's just such a it's just an amazing
thing because
it's such a such it's like the most
dramatic story that has ever been told
or the most like
radically disturbing story that has ever
been told
uh but here and today for some reason
it's for kids
and so and so in the the ancient
images it was very traditional to show
uh
to show dead bodies in the water
uh so for example you can see in this
one
you'll find a similar pattern to what
i'm doing you'll see how it's split in
half
and there's the the right hand of noah
with the white bird
the left hand of noah with the black
bird um
i do it a little differently i really
like how these types of images do it
but i for some reason i couldn't fit it
to do it this way in my image
where you see the white bird here coming
from noah and then on the right side of
noah you see the white bird
finding the branch at the bottom of the
image here
and then you see the blackbird here
feeding on the remainder of the ancient
world
and so this is really a very deep
understanding
of the idea of the blackbird and the
white bird or the left hand and the
right hand
where the branch is
really the uh the idea of structure
that's what a branch is
it's an it's an it's a structure and so
it's a finding of a pattern
and so the the white bird goes off
at first uh can't find the pattern so it
comes back
and then ultimately it goes and then it
does find
the pattern and so it finds the pattern
and brings the the
brings the pattern uh back to noah
and the blackbird goes off and doesn't
return and so the idea of it not
returning has to do
how it is now it
finds the residue of the old world and
that's what the left hand
is like that's what the kind of
symbolism of the dark side of the left
hand is which is this idea of
of recognizing things that aren't part
of the identity and seeing
them and so the blackbird goes off and
feeds off the
off the residue of the ancient world and
usually represented as eating the
carcass of a donkey which makes sense
in terms of the donkey already
representing the foreigner the stranger
representing the wildness of the
wildness that
somehow though can still kind of be
tamed but in scripture
the the uh the idea of the
donkey it really does represent the the
foreign the strange
that which isn't connected to my pattern
so that's how to understand it
so you have the pattern from the white
bird and then you have that which is not
connected to my pattern
uh related to the uh the blackbird um
and so here it's nice because you have
uh you'll have a
a cow here which is a pure animal that
they could eat
on the right side of noah you'll have a
man
who and a woman and then you have an
impure animal which is the donkey
on the left side of noah so all of this
is very very intuitively right
in terms of of these images a lot of
these no ancient no images
are very powerful in that sense so now
if you look at mine
you'll see that i tried to do something
very similar
um you can see though on the right hand
of noah on our left hand on the right
hand no you have the white bird
bringing back the branch to noah
um and so and what i wanted to suggest
was
how the uh can you see this sorry
what i wanted to suggest was how the the
white bird
was carrying a little version of the
tree of life
as the kind of basic pattern of reality
and so i wanted this little branch to
to to have the same motif as the as the
tree of life as well
and then and then at the bottom of the
image you have the blackbird
feeding on the donkey you can't get a
better image than that there's no point
in even trying
such a great such a great way of
representing this
um and so similar similar i wanted i
have
uh you know a man on the right hand of
noah
which is which will be a reflection of
the
sons of noah which on his right hand and
then a woman
on the left side of noah which is a
reflection of his daughters and his wife
on his left hand
and so you'll see that there's this kind
of reflecting where
there's a dead virgin in the water of
that which is alive
uh above and so you know the men the
women
but also at the bottom of the image i
wanted to
show the here you can see there's a
chariot
which is in the waters and of course
this reflects to the chariot above
of uh the chariot of uh the chariot of
enoch this chariot here reflects the
chariot of enoch but it also reflects
the idea of
in the flood not in the flood but the
crossing of the
the waters and the story of moses you
get a sense that it's really important
in the in the song especially miriam
song but in the story that
the chariots of the egyptians are part
of the story
and so the egyptians with their chariots
gets
drowned in the sea and this is also an
image of technology or an image of
civilization itself
it has to do with the descendants of
kane and how the descendants of kane
developed uh technology so the idea that
technology gets swept away
in this flood or that civilization the
walls of the the
the of the temple the walls of the city
get swept away
and so this is why also i have the wall
of a city here which is of course
reflecting the wall of the garden itself
and so this is the this is all of here
is the same thing so the pattern here is
you could say the positive aspect of the
pattern
and then down here is the pattern
breaking down
um because it was at first it was done
pridefully let's say so it ends up
breaking down
so it's it's also a way for me to kind
of try to help people see that all of it
everything is good if it's in the right
place it's not about things being good
or bad it's
always about things not being in the
proper place and so
and so you have the the wall of the city
of course i wanted to put
a warrior with a helmet and a
sword and i want to make the warrior a
little bigger than the one there
just to suggest the giants kind of
getting uh
swept up in all of this and and of
course the the giant here that is
getting swept up
in the flood is a reflection of the
angels
up here um who are properly in their
place
and not doing any of that um
any of that uh intermingling that
they're not supposed to be doing with
the humans
all right so i'm gonna what i'll do is
i'll i'll get through this and then i'll
do
i'll do the two super chats at the end
because i'm seeing people putting
in super chat so i will do the super
chat but i'll do it the way that i
usually do
at the end of the of the conversation so
that i don't kind of break the flow of
what i'm trying to explain
um so i've gone until 11. i'll stop a
little before 11. so we should be able
to get to all this and the super chats
as well
okay and so so i've got pretty much down
here so of course i wanted to show the
fish
down here and the fish you know their
living places in the water
and so they represent the the
possibilities of fish
the possibilities of life in the water i
wanted to have like a blue and a red
fish
just to show let's say the positive and
negative or the
inside outside aspect of the fish as
well
of course the fish will become an image
a very important image for christians
because
they represent christ going down and so
look at the christ goes down into all of
this goes down into the mouth of hell to
get the little fishies
you know to come and fish us out of the
the the death it might seem quaint but
it's not quaint it really is
uh very much an image of what christ is
representing and so i wanted to help
people see that it's
in the flood you already get a sense
that christ is not afraid of the flood
like christ will dive into the flood
and uh is willing to go get the life
hidden
that is even hidden down in the depth of
that of that flood
so that's why i wanted to have the
little fishies down there
and so of course here i forgot this part
of course here you have an
altar which is uh which is now
flooded as well um and it was mostly to
show
let's say the the you could say the
wrong sacrifice you can imagine it as
the sacrifice of cain
the the sacrifices which was which was
rejected by god
um that's what ends up now getting
flooded in the water
all right so let's look at the arc and
so
there's so many interesting ways of
doing the arc and man
it's hard to choose because the the
ancients let me show you a few really
amazing images
of uh of arcs um
okay so this is an image of the ark that
i really love
because the arc is represented just like
a simple house
here you can see again you can see how
uh
the the sons of noah and the daughters
of noah and his wife are separated the
way that i did
it's flip but it's still the same
meaning
and then you have the images of the
animals below
in this kind of tiered structure this is
really a very
very to me it's just the basic sense of
of a
a good way to represent the arc here's
another version of that one
which i like a lot because in this one
you also have the daughters the the
daughters and wife's uh
wife of of noah you have his sons
you have um the bird bringing the branch
back to noah here
and in the ark you have like a hierarchy
of animals which i really
like down here you have the dead man
dead woman like i did
and then you also have the bird eating a
guy now
which is a little intense for me i
didn't want to go all the way there
uh eating a human person uh but then you
see the bird here
uh getting the branch from the tree
and there's like an interesting
hierarchy of animals here where
the birds are represented above so you
can see all of here you have these
different birds
then you have a representation of what
could be called
the tame animals right or the animals
that we kind of understand in terms of
in terms of you know a donkey a horse
uh you know sheep uh cows
all of these kind of animals that we
pigs
gazelles these animals that we're
encountering and as you get lower then
you get all the funky animals
and so you have these like chimera
creatures down here
and you have a griffin and uh
and you even have look at this you even
have monsters
down here can you see the monsters
people
down here it's amazing it's like i
man i love the middle ages so much uh so
down here you have these like little you
have these little monsters there
um so if you want to know where why
they're still monsters after the flood
that's because
it seems some of them were taken into
the ark according to the medievals
and so it ends up being a cosmic image
like i mean that's the idea it's like
you know when i talk to you about the
map of the world and how
you have so imagine now the map of the
world with the humans in the center
and then as you get further you have
these stranger and stranger things and
that's why
just naturally they will they will have
tended to put these monsters on the edge
of the ark it's at the bottom of the ark
close to the edge of the world and so
the ark being a kind of cosmic image
um it just would make sense that you
would do it that way
it's very intuitive
um and so there was something also i
liked about the idea
of i don't think you can
see this let me just
oh you can't see it because it's not
like
all right so i wanted to i really wanted
to have i like this version uh
quite a bit because the the birds are
kind of at the top of the ark
and i really like the idea of the the
ark
having an animal quality to it itself
you know and
it's not just in the ark it boats in
general
the you have this idea of the kind of
the viking ship or
these different um ships that would have
an animal at the mast
at the head of the ship so i really i
really enjoyed i really like this idea
of having the animals coming into the
ark but the ark itself
as having a kind of animal quality to it
and so that's why i made my ark with a
little dragon's head here at the top of
the ark
because there's something about the ark
that is animality itself that that's
it's not all that there's more but there
is an aspect of it and so you can also
understand it as a church
if you understand the ark as the church
then you also
understand that the gargoyle the
gargoyle is on the outside and so i
didn't put my monsters inside the ark
like
those medievals that had a lot of gall
to do that i actually put
my monster on the outside of the ark so
that the gargoyle
is uh is uh is on the outside just like
in the church
which makes total sense
all right so we're actually almost done
i think in terms of
explaining it basically um and so
at the bottom i forgot to talk about the
bottom of the image and so at the bottom
of the image you really have
uh what's known as the mouth of hades
the mouth of death
um those of you that are following the
lord of spirits podcast you will have
you know uh father stephen and father
andrew talked about the mouth of death
there are different ways of representing
this mouth often it's
represented sideways like this
this is often how it's represented in
images of the
last judgment in terms orthodox images
of the last judgment
so you can see down here you have this
kind of image of the mouth of death
so you have christ the judgment and then
all these
these these souls going into this
this mouth of of hades but it is also
often represented uh the way i did which
is
from below this kind of mouth looking up
um
and so i mean it's totally fine to to to
represent it in different ways i really
like
i like this version for what i was doing
because i wanted
i also wanted the uh the mouth of
hell to to be represented
like a container you know like this kind
of this this unholy
vase you could say that's at the bottom
of the world and it's kind of devouring
things
um like the bottom of the ocean
something like that
and so that's how i'd really like the
idea and also of course that it's upside
down
it makes it so easy to so intuitive to
of course to understand the mouth of
death as being kind of upside down and
being the reverse
of the the rainbow um
all right so on the ark now we have the
the sons of adam on his right hand
and the oops sorry and the um
the daughters uh not adam the dog the
sons of noah on his right hand and the
daughters of noah on his left hand
and so this is where i was trying to
kind of play a little bit more
you know trying to experiment a little
bit with color i'm not used to using
color as i am a carver as you all know
but i wanted that so i have um i have no
with white white with dark uh
shadow let's say or a dark reflection
and then i wanted his wife to be kind of
dark with
light reflection um and then
his sons are the primary colors
and the and the daughters are the the
secondary colors
and so that was the idea because it's
almost like you also
understand that it's like the rainbow
playing itself out as well
in the world and so the rainbow has all
the primary and secondary colors
in it you know it's six colors
uh and so that's what i wanted to have
uh down here and so
you can see that you know i have at the
right hand of
of noah the white bird that is the same
white bird is here and then on his left
you have the blackbird which is the same
blackbird that goes down and eats the
donkey
and then i wanted to have this
interesting mirror that i've been
talking about where i have the secondary
colors
uh as the birds above the the sons of
noah
and then have the primary colors as the
birds above
the daughters of noah and to kind of
have this idea of
this kind of idea of this mirrored
causality this
causality in opposites that that i
wanted to suggest and so of course the
birds being at the top
are like angels or principalities at a
lower level or
representation of principalities um just
like these angels that are above here
and so and so now we come to the rainbow
itself and so
so i really wanted the rainbow to be
like the dome of heaven itself
you know and kind of to separate this
cosmic aspect up here the stars
as as uh the let's say the immovable
stars as these
principalities that are that are really
really high and really abstract
and then have this lower pattern under
the under the dome of heaven which is
paradise which is you know the the
ascension of enoch and then the
sacrifice which starts the next world so
kind of like the end in the beginning
and this and this place where it all
comes together in paradise
so of course then now the rainbow
becomes this
this multiplicity above you could say uh
and also an image of the limit at the
same time the rainbow is very
is a very interesting has a very
interesting symbolism because it is
multiplicity and so you always have to
kind of understand the rainbow as a
circle
uh but the circle the this multiplicity
is above and below
and so there's a relationship but i
wanted to for sure show
the white light as the source of the
rainbow so that's why i have the
chrism um the kiro
the the this is a an image of the first
two letters of christ so uh
like this and a row with what looks like
a p as the second letter in the
name of christ and what looks like an x
is the first letter
but what's mostly important in this why
i chose this except
besides the cross like i could have put
a cross there then the more modern
the later images would tend to have a
cross but the reason why i chose the q
row was to really emphasize the six so
you have one
right one you have six points um which
are the six
colors of the rainbow which are now in a
white
circle which is the origin of the six
colors
and so the idea of pure light or
transparent light
as being the the the origin of the
of multiplicity as being the the source
of multiplicity
and so that is the that is the basic
idea i don't know if i'm missing
anything
all right let me look into the uh
into the chat
let's see if people have uh questions if
you have so
i'll look at the super chat but if you
have questions feel like there's
something i haven't talked about
um i will i will answer and so land
abort
for five dollars u.s says
do you have any insight into the old
testament liturgical symbolism and how
the patterns
show shown to moses on the mountain
continue
into the divine liturgy
i mean of course it's not it's not uh
the church itself is based on a
three-part
a three-tiered structure which is the
same structure as the tabernacle or the
temple and so you have an
outside you have an intermediary space
and then you have a total inside
so in my image for example in this in
the image of this
you also have a three-tiered structure
you could say
you basically have i mean you can see it
differently in different ways but you
you have
let's say here this would be something
like the altar
area where you have the incarnate
pattern you could say or the
the top of the mount in the place where
heaven and earth meet
would be up here and so you can
understand all of the garden here as the
as the altar area in the church um and
then
the the this is the nave
um and uh and then
you know let's say that the top part
would be the name maybe and then
this would be the narthex the transition
space oh what i forgot to explain
was the animals i forgot to explain the
logic of the animals my goodness
why didn't anybody tell me and chat or
i'm not looking enough in the chat
to see if anybody's actually talking
about it um
all right so i the logic of the animals
was something that i thought about for
months man it's so hard to get it right
because
there are different ways to do it but uh
it's really fascinating to see you know
how different people do it so here again
in this version of the art
you see the adults on top then you see
the birds
um and then you see the animals but it
doesn't seem like there's a logic
in the animals why they're shown there
and the other one i showed you
there was definitely a logic in the way
the animals were
represented and so
my attempt let's say was to
sep to have to have a sense of
have a sense of like two tiers so it's
three tiers the the ark itself is
is three tiers to to kind of be a
microcosm let's say
of the whole thing which is the three
tiers in the old testament symbolism
and so you have on the right side
here at the top you have pure animals
okay from the old testament rules and on
the left side you have
impure animals okay
now i wanted to have the lamb
and the the line next to each other to
kind of represent the possibility of the
of paradise right this idea of the lamb
and the line
laying together that we see in scripture
but i wanted to have them
across from each other and made sense it
was great because of course the lamb is
the animal of sacrifice too
you know and the lion is the animal of
royalty and so there's something about
that
in terms of of let's say power authority
in power let's say priestly
and kingly let's say was also part of
that
but i also wanted so the animals on the
right hand
to be pure but going towards
so the going towards the giraffe which a
giraffe is actually a pure
animal in the scripture but it's a
foreign it's still exotic it's still
strange
so it's like a strange animal that you
can eat um
and then on the left hand i wanted the
impure animals and so the lion who is
impure but also represents
uh the king um and then
the donkey which is impure but also
rep you know if you think about the idea
of the stranger that can be saved
you get a sense in scripture when christ
enters into jerusalem on the
the back of a donkey there's a sense in
which it's also potentiality that can be
mastered or or you know that can be
embodied and can participate in the
pattern and then the dogs
you know it's all it's all saint
christopher but there's also in the
description of the new jerusalem it says
the dogs will be excluded from the new
jerusalem
and so it was to have them i still
wanted them in there because
there's also a way in which christ talks
about the dogs receiving the crumbs
which fall from the table and so i
wanted them
the dog to be there on the edge
receiving the crumbs from the table you
could say
um all right so down here
is is very fascinating what happened
because
i didn't wasn't sure how to do it like i
wasn't totally sure how to do it so i
wanted to have
it was hard because i wanted to have the
creepy crawlers down there or the lower
animals
um you know the the pig uh
as the boar or the pig as an image of
this wildness
um but there's also there's some
interesting uh
interesting ideas of the pig like
interesting legends especially like
jewish legends about the idea of a
kosher pig or
a pig that will learn to that will kind
of learn to uh
to be reintegrated let's say but so that
was kind of the idea of trying to have
the pig down here
but then the other ones i wanted the
snake on the edge on the left of course
because of
of the fall um
and you know i wanted the locus here
because you can eat them they're
actually a pure animal but it was
kind of struggling but something someone
showed me that i didn't even realize
was how these three the
the locusts the rats and the the frogs
they're the plagues of egypt
and i didn't think of that at all when i
did it but it's just interesting that i
ended up lining them up i could have
chosen any animal like
any kind of of a beast but i ended up
for some reason choosing these
these uh these three animals next to
each other to represent
the plagues of egypt and i didn't plan
it so it's interesting um
and so i wanted like and so you can eat
locust which is make them pure
creepy craw crawlers but you can't eat
uh other other bugs like there's all
these other bugs you can't eat which
aren't which are
you know even though they're trying to
get us to eat bugs you can't eat you're
not supposed to eat bugs at least
not in the old time i mean in the new
testament theory you probably could but
man
let's not eat bugs all right uh so that
was that that's the animals all right
okay so let me sorry let me go back into
the
let me go back into now the super chats
because
i kind of started and then i stopped
all right i got like 10 minutes so let's
try to do this
uh so mike la rivere says if opposites
are driving
toward each other then how do you
understand christ and satan as being
being opposites i don't i don't
understand christ and satan is being
opposites
um i don't i don't think that's a that's
a good uh
a good way to understand opposites in
that terms it'd be like michael and
satan are opposites
um and so they define each other
they also define each other sometimes
not necessarily
in this same productive way and so
imagine michael
killing the dragon and so that's also a
kind of relationship of opposites where
one is defining each other
but it's also a hostile relationship and
so
let's say michael and satan are more
like the so-called
you know jung gets it so wrong when he
says christ and satan are
the the brothers or whatever it's that's
total nonsense they're not
it's like michael and satan are
are closer to the image of the hostile
brothers definitely not christ and satan
um christ contains all of it christ
contains
a lot of people won't understand it when
i say it i'm not saying christ is
is the devil but christ contains uh
let's say everything about the devil
which can be saved
is contained in christ let's say it that
way to
to avoid uh to avoid confusing people
um so james cortez for five day james
good to see you by the way
the incarnation of christ necessitates
the eventual emergence of antichrist
right
if you consider it expressing this
latter part pattern
in your art um
i mean it's yes it's there it's already
there in in certain images in terms of
liturgical images
where you have a sense of uh you know
for example images of the last supper in
the images of the last supper you really
get a sense
of uh judas as this antichrist figure
you see
in an images like the the betrayal of
judas where judas kisses
christ and so it's already there in
liturgical art
but um i mean in terms of my
like that's what my art is my heart is
liturgical arts i just follow the
patterns that have been given to me
um but in terms of the image of
everything it's there
the mouth of hell has this kind of
antichrist idea
you know the leviathan has a kind of
antichrist idea
uh but it's not exactly the same i agree
with you
um it's definitely worth the the image
of antichrist is definitely very very
worth thinking about and trying to
discern because
it's it says that maybe even the
believers will be
duped you know um so james so
so uh gave five dollars thanks so
zero james james again asked if i wanted
to do an embodied symbolic world
gathering
maybe some speakers and a surprise
appearance by a certain enigmatic
familial figure
wouldn't that be great i think so i
would love to do that it's just
i mean kobe made everything complicated
so i don't know how that's going to play
out but
i think it would definitely be great to
have uh to organize an event
richard rowland is talking about doing
something like that which would be in uh
in in uh like organized
also with the publishing of a book which
was kind of bring together a lot of the
symbolic world and symbolic world
adjacent thinkers so
i think in the next few years we're
going to see that happen if we're if
we're allowed to travel and stuff
so
so douglas court for five dollars says
he agrees with james and he says let's
have
a symbolic world party at the edge of
the world yeah let's do it i'm totally
for it
i definitely would love to do that
all right so jeremy first for ten
dollars says he's a little bit late but
it says two other royal figures
associated with the sun and the moon
above the rainbow and so these are
traditional ways of representing the sun
and moon
uh which is to represent one as a king
and a queen
and so a way to understand it is to
understand it exactly as that it says in
scripture
that god made the sun to rule the day
and the lesser
light the moon to rule the night so you
can understand that in terms of a
masculine
principality like a king you can
understand the moon as a feminine
principality
like the you know like that rules over
the night so it's like light and dark
uh you know so that's the traditional
way of representing
them sometimes they're not represented
male and female sometimes they're just
ambiguous
but often they're represented as male
and female not just in christianity but
in also pagan cultures as well
um and you know uh father stephen and
father andrew
on the lord of spirits they've been
talking about how it it's
there's also a sense in which these
images are represent the principalities
which govern these bodies that is the
sun is not just a big
ball of flaming gas you know the fact
that it it
rules over our lives it rules over our
existence means that
behind the sun there's also
a principality and you see this
principality
kind of submitting to christ in in the
image of the crucifixion
kind of hiding themselves uh you know
in in this kind of reverence towards
christ in
in the crucifixion and you see similar
images
other kind of similar images as well
right so taylor
lewis 50 50r i don't know what r is but
thank you
that's very kind of you um and so i
think
right let's see okay so here uh ac for
fifty dollars
u.s are you familiar with corbin's
interpretation of the flood
as flood soft gnosis the dogmatic
refuses to build
a new ark for but with floods of
gnosis demonic self crowning is all you
get
and battle for law speech comes i'm not
sure
i don't know if there's something wrong
with the way that you uh floods of
gnosis
um the dogmatic refuses to build a new
arc for
i mean i don't know i've never read
corbin's combines interpretation i
haven't read a lot of copy i've read
some
but not not a lot um i don't
i don't i don't know i mean i don't
think that
i don't like that it's use the word
gnosis it it could be
you could it could be a flood of
information that could definitely be a
way to understand it in the sense that
sometimes a flood happens when new facts
emerge and so
these facts appear and so
you have to if you're not able to kind
of build an arc from the old world
then everything's going to get dissolved
because all of a sudden
things don't fit anymore right you know
you have to adjust
the pattern to the emergent
facts to a certain extent you have to be
able to
to to adjust it or else it's gonna it's
gonna break so you can see
how um you could say that one of the
things that happened
in the scientific era it was an
incapacity to do that
where all these scientific facts were
kind of appearing and
religious people tried to resist
the facts or or mal-adjust to the facts
and that's one of the things that
created the
that's one of the things that created
the problem of modernism you know which
is that you have this
alien you have this kind of
schizophrenic worldview or on the one
hand you
you have these mythological
spiritual patterns on the other hand you
have the scientific kind of
vision of the world and you can't fit
them together and so because of it you
have this alienation
and those that try to fit it together
are doing it in all kinds of weird ways
and uh
you know and it doesn't it just doesn't
jive so it doesn't doesn't work so
maybe that way i could understand it but
um the word gnosis for me
has a very particular meaning especially
a christian meaning it has
similar to the sense of symbolism which
is really this joining of heaven and
earth that's where gnosis happens
um so all right guys so yeah i i said i
would stop a little bit for
11 and i think we got through everything
um and so i'm really i'm really happy to
see
everybody uh show up in the chat it was
a lot of fun
and so let me see
all right so so yeah so so i i might do
this
i might do this more often if it's easy
because i kind of i kind of like the
direct contact as well
um and it uh it's less complicated i
don't have to kind of edit everything
and think it out
i can make mistakes and you all forgive
me because you'll know it's a live chat
so thanks for your support everybody
thanks for your attention there are
more videos coming soon my next video
that's coming up will be a discussion
with
voter laskin the author of loris which i
recorded a few weeks ago
and uh more discussion with richard
rowland are coming down the line as well
as well as my video on the mark of the
beast which
which which i want to make sure i get
right before i put out so
so thanks everybody and i'll talk to you
very soon